I really need to buy some cold end I do
not feel well Facebook ad for cold end
that's creepy by the way cold end isn't
a real product but just go with it
you've probably heard the conspiracy
theory Facebook is listening to your
microphone to better target ads at you
but that's just not true
Facebook does not use your phone's
microphone to inform ads or to change
what you see in newsfeed Facebook told
me other experts including former
Facebook employees said there are
technical not to mention legal reasons
it isn't true so why does it feel like
Facebook and its advertisers are in the
same room as you because they've gotten
so good at tracking you online and even
offline that it feels like they're
listening
plain old tissues or fancy lotion
tissues
both I guess so how do advertisers know
about this situation well if you use a
loyalty card at a physical store your
purchase history could be used to target
ads to you on Facebook how do the
contents of what's in this bag make its
way back to Facebook a third party data
collector gathers that purchase data
from stores then typically a brand say
cold end buys that information and uses
Facebook tools to match up offline data
with Facebook accounts and then that ad
shows up in your news feed yes
Facebook and advertisers are actually
following your footsteps the Facebook
app in your pocket and many others
gather your location using various
methods IP addresses Wi-Fi networks
around you and most likely your direct
permission to use your phone's location
so say this made-up cold medicine
company decided to market to people in
areas where the flu or winter colds have
hit the hardest location tracking has
gotten so advanced that marketers could
also target me because I'm just a few
blocks away from their store or product
[Music]
according to this medical website I've
been blowing my nose the wrong way
Facebook has a product called pixel and
it basically does exactly what this guy
is doing it's installed on hundreds of
thousands of websites and apps so
advertisers and Facebook can track your
web and app activity Facebook uses that
info and all the other things that knows
about you from your Facebook use to then
pick your ads Facebook says we build our
targeting tools in a way that doesn't
share people's personal information with
advertisers and that gives people
control over the ads they see I suggest
you start by going into Facebook
settings account settings ads and
turnoff interest-based ads on the iPhone
you can also go into settings privacy
advertising and then select limit ad
tracking I suggest you make some time to
follow the tips so you can create at
least some distance between you and this
guy
[Music]